Dustin is with us in Ohio hi Dustin how
are you I'm good a new South babe
better than I deserve what's up hey I
just had a question for you wanted some
advice I'm in the process of enlistment
with the military and my question is
what is your advice on best being
responsible with my family ances long
story short I have a fiance and a four
year old that's gonna be at home and I
want to make sure I'm doing everything
right that's going to set us all up for
the future because the goal is
retirement with the military what is
your advice on it good for you thank you
for your service how old are you I just
turned 25 last month okay what are you
gonna be doing the goal is to be a
sensory operator I'd be a drone pilot
and I am attempting to cross-train in
cybersecurity good okay very good
all right fun um well I mean there's
really no difference in what you would
do you would follow the baby steps that
we teach make sure you're out of debt
you have an emergency fund and of three
to six months of expenses and then you
begin saving 15% of your income in Roth
IRAs and you can use the Thrift Savings
Plan to do some of that if you want to
Roth Roth selection and we recommend 80%
see 10% eye 10% ass in the Thrift
Savings Plan and but I would do a
regular Roth IRA for you and your wife
each and then above that do the thrift
because you can beat the TSP right what
it's performed it's a good the sees good
plan but you can beat what it's done in
the open market with good mutual funds
cuz it's basically an S&P then you would
save are you do you feel like most of
the time in the military they're gonna
move you every couple of years you feel
like that's gonna be using me more than
likely her she will more than likely
stay in Ohio because she runs a hair
salon and I can't I can't ask her to
leave that because those well you're
gonna get married and you're gonna live
in Hawaii and she's gonna live in Ohio
as of right now that's what it's gonna
look like but there's a big chance that
I'll be here in Ohio because of the
creosote I'll be a lot of the drums are
actually piloted out of Springfield Ohio
yeah so I've got about a 75% chance but
there is always that chance that I'm not
here and if it requires her to move and
you know that's the step we'll take yeah
okay because I mean you don't want be
separated for two years from your wife
yeah yeah no absolutely and you're
living in the States I mean if you're
deployed or something that'd be a
different situation but right absolutely
then the other thing and I this would
normally be my warning to young
non-married enlistees I don't think that
I mean the you know the 18 or 19 year
old the biggest danger and we work with
the military all the time we love
military folk is that when you leave the
gates of most any military installation
as you leave the gates on each side of
the road for the next two miles is every
stupid thing a human can do absolutely
and a lot of it is around money some of
it is just immoral activities but a lot
of it is around money and so you can
pawn stuff I mean you can tied up on
your car you can rent to own you can do
every stupid but thing you can pay
somebody $50 to cash your check I mean
you can just do every stupid but thing
for the next two miles down the road on
each side and just don't fall into that
and let it mess up your finances or your
life because there's a certain number of
people out there that prey on 19 year
olds with their first check come in the
military and their first taste of
freedom from their mamas kitchen you
know nobody there to smack them with a
wooden spoon right and so it's
definitely a big mistake that I hear
about all the time and it's one of those
ones that I personally know to avoid and
it's just I want to you know I've had a
lot of military people come in through
my work you know recommending you to
talk to specifically and know you know
I've got a four year old son I think
you're more stable than what I'm talking
about that's why I
that's when I'm not my normal that's my
normal advice when I'm talking to the
guys and gals but I think you're
probably a you know you're a life phase
ahead of that and so you know you got a
four year old kid a wife you're you know
you're probably not gonna fall for all
that but just be careful that you don't
fall for anything out there in the
public and you just walk these baby
steps hold on I'm gonna send you a copy
of the book the Total Money Makeover
which I outline exactly what you should
do and it's our gift just for saying
thank you or just as we say thank you
for your service and where you're headed